♪ (EERIE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(SCREAMS)
(BABY CRIES)
Imagine if a baby fell
out the sky
and fell into your arms.
What would you be thinking?
Open the bag for me, miss.
(BABY COOS)
(LOUD CRASH)
Fuck.
Imagine a woman,
never wanted a child,
in her mid-30s,
searching for something
in her life,
but it isn't a baby.
I wanted
the audience's first impression
to really be what mine was,
of like, "Wow."
And that it's a comedy-horror,
you know.
I just love the combination
of genres.
Can I leave this with you?
We came up with the show
when we were traveling
a couple of years ago.
The idea kind of
fell out of the sky.
It just felt like a kind of
wacky comedy-horror premise.
And then as the story evolved,
and through
the development process,
we kind of realized
that actually it was becoming
more and more about
the deep ambivalence
that we both were feeling about
whether we would become parents.
I think I've forgotten
how normal people behave.
SIÂN ROBINS-GRACE: I guess
one of the big themes is love,
and the way we're kind of told
we should love each other,
and the ways we actually do.
The main theme's sisterhood,
just sort of family
and community,
and mothering and motherhood.
The show is centered
around three women,
Natasha, her sister Bobbi,
and Mrs. Eaves.
Bobbi's a real people pleaser.
She's a real bubbly person.
Macadamia nut?
No.
AMIRA GHAZALLA: Mrs. Eaves,
I think she's very unique.
There is so much courage
in the way the story's written,
and the way we're telling it.
MICHELLE DE SWARTE: I think
it's a real compassionate,
funny, scary, dark,
enlightening look at motherhood.
You had a baby?
But you don't--
you don't want a baby.
AMBER GRAPPY: It's light,
and it's fun sometimes,
and equally scary and dark.
It just has so much versatility.
It's a totally original show.
Come, be ready to laugh,
and be a bit frightened.
Connect to some
of the characters
and connect to some
of the stories.
Ta-da!
And hopefully have a bit
to think about
in terms of mothering
and motherhood.
♪ (EERIE MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪